every time he thinks he's out they pull
him back in so why is the man known to
the criminal underworld as Baba Yaga so
bad at staying retired here's what we
know so far about the backstory of films
greatest assassin John wick it isn't
until the third installment of the John
wick franchise that we learn anything
about the early life and upbringing of
everyone's favorite dog loving hitman in
many ways even the small bits of
information we do get are coated with
symbolism meant to lead the audience to
draw their own conclusions here's what
we know
Bourne jarred Donnie jovanovich in
Belarus he was orphaned as a child and
adopted by the Ruska Roma which is the
name of both an ethnic group and a
criminal syndicate he then began
training as an assassin under a woman
known as the director in the guise of
studying at a Performing Arts Institute
in New York City we're not sure when he
changed his name but jar Donnie is the
equivalent name to John in the Romani
language we also don't know when exactly
John received all of his tattoos but as
we get a short tour of the directors
Institute we see that the older students
are already heavily tattooed with
Catholic imagery similar to John's
possibly indicating they've gone through
a similar initiation into the assassin
underworld we also see the students in
the process of various kinds of training
from dancing to wrestling and so much
more
given that our boy John is an expert
marksman and Driver
a skilled martial artist across a number
of different styles experienced in
hand-to-hand combat with virtually every
weapon and resilient enough to walk off
a back-alley surgery with no anesthetic
they've probably got more going on there
to the most obvious and definitive thing
we know about John's past is what we're
directly told in the first movie John is
a man of focus
before settling down with his wife WIC
was an incredibly proficient and
prolific assassin who quickly earned the
nickname of Baba Yaga for being the hit
man so lethal that he terrified the
other hit men after leaving the husk
aroma John joined the Tarasov mob as one
of the main enforcers for its leader
Vigo Tarasov during this time John
developed different relationships with
people at various levels of the high
table the ruling body of this criminal
underworld with delegates from each of
the twelve families in charge of it
seems all crime everywhere John
developed a friendly relationship with a
few allies including the staff of the
assassin friendly Continental Hotel
particularly its stickler for the rules
manager Winston unfortunately he also
made a collection of frenemies along the
way among his rival killers as is to be
expected in the assassin game at some
point during the assassin years John
crossed paths with Sophia another dog
lover and assassin who would go on to
manage the Casablanca branch of the
Continental John helps to get Sophia's
daughter to safety from the mob and in
return
he receives a blood oath marker from her
these markers are made of elaborate gold
designs and opened like a locket inside
they have room for two thumb prints the
first establishing the oath and the
second when the oath has been fulfilled
by returning any favor they ask no
matter what the relationship might be
between the two parties they are
absolutely non-negotiable if someone has
your marker you owe them period this is
your blood your pawned when you needed
help I was there at the heart of this
action franchise is an operatic love
story that ends in tragedy
John falls in love with a woman named
Helen and knows he has no choice but to
get out of the assassin game when he
approaches Vigo Tarasov about retiring
the crime lord seizes the moment to take
full advantage of John's new
vulnerability I gave him
not impossible tasks a job no one could
have pulled off Vigo tasks John with
taking out all of his rival leaders in a
single night and against all odds he
does while John earned his freedom
through his staggering body count he
wasn't able to pull it off alone he
gives his blood oath marker to the son
of the head of the Rome syndicate
Santino Dantonio for tactical assistance
this will prove to be one of the biggest
mistakes of John Wick's life the blood
marker ends up being the price of five
years with his beloved Helen before she
passes away from cancer
shattering him in a way that he'd never
been broken before she was his anchor in
the real world outside of the assassin
game as a final gift Helen leaves John a
puppy named Daisy someone new for him to
take care of and help him remember his
humanity and all the love he has in his
heart John isn't out of the game long
but those five years were still long
enough for the next generation of
mobsters to forget who he was and what
he's capable of apparently even the bad
guys don't tell their kids bedtime
stories about a guy who once took out
three men with a pencil as John is
filling up at a gas station near his
home a young hoodlum asked to buy John's
muscle car from him which John refuses
this happens to be Viggo Tarasov son
Yosef who decides to get a crew together
storm John's house assault him and steal
his car they also killed John's puppy
which will prove to be the biggest
mistake of anyone's life ever badly
injured and emotionally devastated once
more
John's grief turns to pure unbridled
rage while Viggo tries to negotiate a
solution that doesn't end with a very
crowded Terrace off mausoleum John digs
up the remnants of his former career a
trove of markers gold coins and weapons
cemented underneath his garage with
Joseph in his sights
John wick makes a return to his old life
with one thing on his mind
revenge people keep asking if I'm back
and I haven't really had an answer but
now yeah
I'm taking on back in the meantime Vigo
sends his own assassins after John but
well the movie isn't called miss Perkins
is it after an enormous death toll that
takes out Vigo Yosef miss Perkins and
dozens more
John adopts a pitbull who is set to be
put down the next day and goes home
knowing quite well that John wick was
battered after his war with the Tara
sobs an opportunistic Santino Dantonio
pulls John back into the underworld even
further by cashing in his own marker
Santino's request take out his sister
Gianna who's been selected to represent
their family at the high table so he can
assume her throne
John can't refuse the marker so he sadly
reluctantly flies to Rome where he uses
gold coins to get a stylish but tactical
wardrobe as well as weapons when he
arrives at Gianna's ascendance party a
gorgeous affair set in roman ruins she
knows what her brother has done and
chooses to end things herself to
maintain what little agency she has left
the job is now done but Santino can't
leave well enough alone he lies and puts
a hit of $7,000,000 out on John wick for
assassinating his sister that leads to
another huge showdown with a dozen
assassins once again we see John
emerging as the victor but not without
cost back in New York
John is forced to visit the Bowery King
a low-level player in the hitman game
but he has access to his own resources
he gives John seven bullets one for each
million of the bounty you don't want me
going you
santino flees to the Continental because
the rules that govern the assassins
forbid doing business on the hotels
grounds if you've been along for the
ride so far
it will not surprise you that this
particular rule does not stop John wick
from getting revenge pulling off a hit
on continental grounds results in
immediate excommunication from the
entire underworld Network that was once
available to John wick because he knows
that Santino set John up Winston gives
him an hour to escape before putting in
the excommunicate order but he can't
stop the other assassins tell them all
whoever comes whoever it is badly
injured and running out of time John
goes to the New York Public Library
where he has stashed away a photograph
of his wife Helen as well as a rosary
and more markers inside a hollowed-out
book of Russian folktales while there a
giant assassin tries to kill him before
the hour-long grace period is up but
fails when John takes him down with a
library book that might be even more
impressive than using a pencil John
manages to make it to a friendly face in
the form of a doctor who begins tending
his wounds but isn't able to finish
before the hour is up leaving John to
finish stitching himself when the hour
is up more bounty hunters arrived to
attack John in a museum of ancient
weapons which is arguably the worst
place outside of a pet store to fight
John wick sure enough our boy John
defeats everyone and stumbles his way
back to where he started in New York as
a child
the directors Performing Arts Institute
the director decides to help him
securing his passage to Casablanca where
he will try to connect with the only
person above the high table who can save
his life the elder in the process the
director brands over John's back tattoo
he has cashed his ticket the Institute
Andrew sky Roma are no longer his allies
as John wick travels by boat to Morocco
a new emissary of the high table enters
the mix the adjudicator arrives in
Manhattan to mete out the consequences
of John's actions since Santino called
in John's marker there are rules
they are the only things that separate
us yes every person who helped John
receives severe punishments while
Winston goes into hiding to avoid the
adjudicators sentencing in Casablanca
John meets with Sophia the manager of
Morocco's Continental Hotel who doesn't
look happy to see him or his marker to
her dismay however she made the blood
oath to John when he helped Sophia get
her daughter into hiding years before
and as we saw with Santino
there's no refusing when that favour
gets called in Sophia and her two German
Shepherds finally agreed to help which
involves going to Sophia's old boss
bharata the man in charge of minting the
mysterious coins used in the assassin
world bharata tells them how to find the
elder then demand sophia give him one of
her beloved dogs in exchange for the
information she refuses and bharata
shoots the dog which is less than
advisable when dealing with john and his
friends fortunately this pup has a
bulletproof vest who shot my dog i get
it sophia and john fight dozens of
bharata's henchmen before defeating them
all with the dogs getting in on the
action to get their own revenge as well
following bharata's instructions john
wanders the desert until he's found by
the elder and agrees to be back in
service to the high table for the rest
of his days no exceptions to prove his
fealty he cuts off his ring finger with
his wedding ring on it and offers it as
a tribute to the elder John's first task
for the high table is to return to
Manhattan and kill Winston with the
members of the table feel has gotten too
high on his own power in the meantime
the 14 million dollar bounty is still on
John's head and he has to battle more
minions in order to get to Winston
including the Acolytes of ninja trainers
Xero played by former Iron Chef America
Chairman Mark Dacascos
John can't bring himself to kill his
longtime Ally though and defies the high
tables order once again the adjudicator
D consecrates the Continental meaning
it's open season on John and Winston who
take on an army of assassins sent by the
high table to claim their bounties
including some of John's biggest fans oh
pretty good fight huh yeah after the
massive battle that follows Winston and
the adjudicator come to an understanding
Winston decides to sell out his old
friend and agrees to kill John himself
to get the hotel reconsecrated and
maintain his position as manager Winston
shoots John several times point-blank
and John falls from the roof to what
should have been his death but the
Bowery King has his own power and his
own score to settle with the high table
his minion the tick-tock man rescues
John and brings him down to the Bowery
to plan another round of revenge check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one